♪ ♪ ♪
- Mais regardez ça!
C'est du béton!
Ça, c'est la place publique.
- Qu'est-ce qui vous choque?
- C'est pas un environnement
campagnard, ça, c'est comme...
on se penserait à... Blainville,
à Laval. C'est pas beau!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Danièle Adam habite
Mont-Tremblant depuis 2004.
En 17 ans, elle a été aux
premières loges de plusieurs
projets de développement.
- Regardez comme c'est désolant.
- Comme celui qui
doit voir le jour ici :
un projet de maisons de ville
sur un terrain de golf.
DANIÈLE ADAM,
résidente de Mont-Tremblant
- Ça a été terrible, la réaction
des gens, ils trouvaient ça
épouvantable. C'est un golf
centenaire. Ça fait partie
du patrimoine, ça. Il faut
penser aux générations futures;
c'est pas juste maintenant.
C'est que... ici, on veut
en faire une ville,
puis c'est supposé être
un village de campagne.
- Ça va faire 5,75 $,
s'il vous plaît.
- C'est justement l'appel
de la nature qui a poussé
Audrey Pratte à venir
s'installer à Tremblant
et à changer de carrière
en ouvrant une épicerie
de quartier.
AUDREY PRATTE,
résidente de Mont-Tremblant
- Nous, on fait partie
des statistiques, là...
(rires)
En fait, nous, on avait
une vie paisible, donc travail
au centre-ville et une maison
à Montréal, puis on venait ici
plus le week-end à Tremblant...
faire du ski avec les enfants et
tout, puis... avec la pandémie,
on a décidé de s'installer ici
pour le télétravail.
- Comme bien des municipalités
des Laurentides, Mont-Tremblant
a attiré beaucoup de néoruraux
pendant la pandémie.
- On est contents d'avoir
les gens, mais ça a créé
une pression, si on veut,
supplémentaire.
- Une pression sur les services,
les infrastructures,
le tourisme, mais surtout
sur le développement immobilier.
De l'aveu même du maire sortant,
ça va trop vite.
LUC BRISEBOIS, maire sortant et
candidat mairie, Mont-Tremblant
- On peut faire notre mea culpa,
il y en a une couple, oui,
qu'on a échappées. On veut
tout révisait les zonages.
On s'est aperçus que
des gens étaient inquiets.
C'est là qu'on a dit :
écoutez, il faut mettre un top,
il faut repenser à l'immobilier,
il faut regarder
ce qui se passe.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Selon les données fournies par
la Ville, les permis octroyés
pour les habitations neuves
sont passés de 137 en 2020
à 249 en date d'octobre 2021.
Le rythme effréné a poussé
le conseil municipal à agir
pour geler les projets
de construction pendant
trois mois, en adoptant
un règlement en octobre,
en pleine campagne électorale
municipale, alors que pour
la première fois en plus
de 15 ans, Mont-Tremblant
a droit à une véritable course
à la mairie à deux candidats.
MICHEL SAVARD, candidat
à la mairie, Mont-Tremblant
- Ça prend du sang neuf.
Si on avait été un peu plus
proactifs, si on avait été
capables de développer
une vision à long terme
il y a quelques années,
il y a de grosses chances
qu'on ne serait pas dans
le contexte actuel d'avoir
à créer cette pause-là.
- Luc Brisebois est à la tête
de la Ville depuis 2013.
Élu sans opposition pour
deux mandats, le dernier marqué
par le conflit sur l'abolition
de la police municipale, dans
lequel il disait avoir vécu
de l'intimidation de la part
de certains policiers.
- Quand tu dis que tu envoies
ta conjointe au Mexique
quand tu passes une résolution
parce qu'elle a peur et elle
pleure, à un moment donné,
j'ai vécu des choses, certain!
- Qu'est-ce qui fait que
vous vous représentez?
- Bien moi, je pense
qu'on a fait un bon travail.
On a fait ce qu'on a dit.
- On n'est pas contre
le développement immobilier,
loin de là.
- Pas contre, mais plutôt en
faveur préserver l'environnement
et le cachet de la communauté;
c'est ce que souhaite
le regroupement
Les Amis de Mont-Tremblant,
avec près de 500 citoyens,
dont Jean-Luc Trahan.
- Il est certain que l'enjeu,
c'est : qu'est-ce que
Tremblant va devenir?
- C'est la question de l'urne,
selon lui, qui pousserait
à revoir l'aménagement
et l'urbanisme.
JEAN-LUC TRAHAN, membre,
Les Amis de Mont-Tremblant
- Je pense qu'on est chanceux
que pour la première fois
en 20 ans, il y ait
vraiment des élections.
- C'est l'équipe Savard
contre l'équipe Brisebois,
donc c'est un plus pour nous
puisqu'il peut y avoir
des débats, des échanges
et qu'on puisse voir
le choix que l'on a.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un choix pour
une ville touristique
à la croisée des chemins.
- Pensez-vous déménager?
- Je resterai pas ici longtemps.
Je connais des gens
qui sont partis à cause
de ce qui se passe ici.
- C'est sûr que moi, en tant
que résidente de Mont-Tremblant,
c'est sûr qu'on veut garder
l'accès à cette nature-là.
En tant que commerçant, c'est
sûr qu'on trouve ça intéressant
d'avoir un développement qui
est important parce qu'on voit
quand même un fort potentiel
pour notre commerce.
Mais je pense que c'est
de garder cet équilibre-là
entre les deux.
- Un équilibre fragile et
plutôt difficile à trouver.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Mont-Tremblant.